[Musique]
messieurs bonsoir bienvenue dans votre
émission 7,8 débat les verts a fait une
irruption fracassante dans les yvelines
depuis mardi la neige mais aussi le
verglas ont semé la pagaille
automobilistes coincés sur la n118 gares
saturées transports scolaires annulés
météo france a prévu de nouvelles chutes
de neige demain matin nous le titre de
cette émission chutes de neige un chaos
inévitable pour répondre à cette
question j'ai accueilli autour de moi le
maire de vélizy villacoublay pascal
thévenot qui a notamment dû faire face
aux naufragés de la haine ce 10 118
excusez moi mais également michael tan
secrétaire général adjoint de la fcpe 78
une fédération de parents d'élèves
bonsoir à vous de fuir merci d'avoir
accepté cette invitation
malgré l'accalmie d'aujourd'hui météo
france a maintenu les yvelines en alerte
orange à cause du risque lié au verglas
et il a prévu pour demain notamment
jusqu'à 7 cm de précipitations de neige
la préfecture demande à tout à chacun de
ne pas utiliser ces véhicules est ce que
on va d'abord faire le point notamment
pour la journée de demain vous en tant
que maire d'une commune des yvelines à
ce que vous avez pris des dispositions
des dispositifs naissait en plus
frustrant pour prévoir ses nouvelles
chutes de neige maintenant on fait on
al'avantage d'avoir vécu des gens 2010
manière fracassante
donc depuis l'alerté neige de lundi
j'ai toutes les équipes de voirie c'est
une quarantaine de personnes dont une
vingtaine d'équipages qui n'ont pas
arrêté
de traiter et la voirie justement pour
éviter le blocage et permettre au
transit et aux salariés puisque ville
isis et 50 mille salariés donc vous
imaginez cinquante mille salariés
bloqués et pour qu'ils puissent en fait
partir et c'est ce qui s'est passé mardi
soir c'est qu'on a eu quelques naufragés
en transit mais on n'a eu aucun salarié
v lien qui n'avaient pas pu repartir
puisque les entreprises aussi elles ont
vécu en 2010 donc ont pris les devants
et ont libéré leurs salariés dès 16
heures on reviendra de fautes alors
notamment sur les cadeaux la n118 et
vous en tant que parent d'élève parce
que vous avez eu des nouvelles
dispositions pour demain pour faire face
notamment une nouvelle fois
l'interdiction des bus scolaires de
circuler dans le département
effectivement les puces on est en
liaison avec la csdn donc services de
l'inspection académique
justement pour avoir une vision de la
vie
la situation départementale on a aussi
consulté nos conseils locaux en fait
qu'ils sont les parents de différents
établissements pour voir quel était leur
niveau d'information dans la plupart de
cas et il a ils ont indiqué qu'ils
étaient relativement satisfait du niveau
d'information et pas toujours parfait à
mon sens il ya des choses qu'on peut
encore améliorer
il était relativement satisfait de ce
niveau d'information donc c'est à dire
que demain n'aura pas d'enfant tout seul
face à des écoles ou des collèges alors
en fait
je crois que ce qui est relativement
intéressant c'est qu'ils aient le
meilleur niveau de communication au
niveau local c'est à dire qu'il ya des
endroits où par exemple la restauration
n'était pas mais il n'y avait pas de
restauration scolaire alors que par
contre les élèves étaient accueillis
donc ça c'est après aux parents de 2,2
joue enfin de voir quelle est la réelle
la réelle situation façon à choisir ce
qu'il leur est possible de faire mais il
ya effectivement c'est effectivement
difficile pour pour les parents parfois
que s'organiser mais c'est la météo qui
veut ça demain est en fait il toujours
une école après la difficulté c'est le
personnel d'encadrement
donc le message qu'on a redonné encore
ce soir c'est tous les enfants sont
accueillis dans les crèches la même
chose mais si vous avez la possibilité
ou si vous ne travaillez pas ne venez
pas à l'état doit la crèche ce ne serait
pas facturés mais est ce que justement
il ya eu un appel notamment à part des
parents d'élèves pour que les écoles et
les crèches ferme beaucoup plus tard
pour les c'est justement à chaque parent
le temps de récupérer leurs enfants
alors nous on n'a pas fait d'appel
spécifique mais anton tient certainement
on sait très bien que les les mairies ou
en tout cas on sera attentif à ce que
les mairies essaient de faire leur
maximum pour pour
dans cette situation exceptionnelle mais
par exemple il ya un pour le lycée
agricole de saint germain ils ont décidé
de de clore les dès mardi je crois sauf
erreur de ma part
ils ont arrêté les cours mais par contre
il en est un qui est aussi des internes
ils ont éclairé c'est un lycée agricole
donc les élèves viennent parfois très
loin
il continue à accueillir les élèves
mais leur souci c'était justement pour
demain pour que les élèves puissent
rentrer chez eux puisqu'il se dit
parfois très loin et donc qu'il se
préparait à une petite a des difficultés
à ce moment pendant justement parlons en
difficulté le gros on va dire des
problèmes c'est notamment mardi ou en
ile de france on a rompu un nouveau mât
battu un nouveau record notamment en
terme dans deux pots triage près de 700
kilomètres d'embouteillages cumulés
c'est vraiment énorme c'est la distance
entre paris montpellier juste en région
ile de france
comment peut-on expliquer comment
peut-on expliquer ce phénomène
déjà juste sur les
les horaires en fait non les horaires
ont pas bougé par contre on se retrouve
avec une quarantaine d'écoliers dans les
parents on n'avait pas pu venir et il
n'y a pas une finalité qui va leur dire
dehors
l'heure est terminée donc on les a
regroupés on ferait occupés et le
dernier parti à 21h donc ça sera de
toute façon comme ça même si l'horaire a
pas changé pour les parents d'élèves
mais par contre justement comment
peut-on expliquer cet embouteillage
monstre qui a eu lieu il ya du jour ya
deux jours je pense que si je prends une
ce retour d'expérience et l' alerte
neige n'a peut-être pas beaucoup de sens
pour beaucoup de franciliens qui n'ont
jamais vécu et c'est ce qui nous est
arrivé rend peut-être en 2010 puis avec
moins d'anticipation et il faut savoir
que la route peut être dégagée mais s'il
ya une alerte neige avec 20 cm 1 mardi
dernier ou 7 voire 10 cm demain ça veut
pas dire que si c'est clair où j'en ai
un instant vous voulez partir vous
pouvez vous retrouver qu'on sait et le
mieux c'est soit de prendre ses
précautions ou de ne pas circuler
d'ailleurs
c'est peut-être aussi au niveau
communication le ministère avait
déconseillé de prendre sa voiture
là maintenant
le préfet de police demande aux gens de
rester chez eux et pas prendre leur
voiture
je pense que c'est ce degré là et c'est
peut-être après ils ont discuté en
aparté mais peut-être venir à imposer
aussi en hiver à avoir déplu neige où on
pas se déplacer quand vous en avez pas
besoin
mais globalement il eu 700 km des jeux
10 c il faut se poser pour regarder
pourquoi quand on parle de 2000
véhicules qui étaient dans la veille de
la bièvre sur 118 bloqués c'est ce qui
nous était arrivé en 2010 sur le tronçon
vélizy pont-de-sèvres là des mesures
avaient été prises
et finalement on en a eu très peu et ce
qui a fait qu'on est passé dans le
centre d'accueil de 1500 personnes en
2010 à un peu moins de 200
en cette année mardi soir et sachant que
la majorité n'était pas des naufragés de
la route
mais dijon qui travaillaient qu'ils
étaient en vie d' équité union
transports en commun qui sont
ressortissants transports en commun non
c'est là que la préfecture a pris des
mesures et les a transférées sur le
centre d'accueil pour vous justement ce
que vous considérez que la communication
a été suffisamment efficace que ça a été
clair pour vous notamment qu'il fallait
éviter de prendre sa voiture parce que
pour préparer l'émission de m'expliquer
que vous même vous avez été coincé sur
une départementale donc là donc j'étais
coincé deux
de 4h30 enfin coincé c'est à dire que je
suis parti de chez moi 4h30 pour
chercher mes enfants et je suis rentré à
20h30 en ayant un parcours en essayant
de trouver la bonne voie sachant que
pour ma part je suis équipé de deux
pneus quatre saisons et donc j'étais je
pouvais rouler mais par contre
effectivement comme vous disiez fait
effectivement visiblement un certain
nombre d'automobilistes ont été surpris
un guide pour différentes raisons
soit parce que ils connaissent pas trop
les la neige ils savent pas forcément
rouler dans ce type de conditions
en suède on passe dans son permis on
passe on est une partie sur 7 800 c'est
à dire qu'il faut inciter ou interdire
les personnes à prendre leur voiture
quelques questions les solutions
notamment pour éviter toute cette
histoire parce qu'après tout la france
plus riches on se prépare pour les
prochains gilliot c'est quand même un
pays où ne devrait pas trembler pour dix
centimètres de neige on devrait pas
améliorer ça arrive non pas de 2010 2018
donc c'est quand même pas tous les ans
c'est sûr quelques jours et il faut
force à traiter ces situations mais il
faut
ne pas prendre son véhicule qu'en sas
arriver au niveau de la communication
est améliorer la communication être plus
insistants quand il ya un réel danger
tant que les gens le comprennent
mais je vous dis moi je suis nature un
peu optimiste je pense que tous ceux qui
se sont trouvés bloqués dans l'essai 100
km de bouchons 1 mardi dernier
si ça arrive dans le temps ils s'en
souviendront et soyez pour non pas leur
véhicule et rentreront beaucoup plus tôt
c'est ce que nous on a vécu mais ensuite
après c'est plus bas de communication
parce que ça arrivera toujours et de
voir comment on peut communiquer aux
gens que l'on sait où ils sont qui
seront traités qui sont pas abandonnées
parce qu'il ya aussi cette recette peur
et c'est ce qui est arrivé
quand on entend certains automobilistes
qui seront qu étaient bloqués qui ont vu
les premiers secours arrivés à 5 heures
du matin ça peut faire peur et donc ça
peut être compliqué à gérer il faut je
pense à améliorer la communication et la
manière dont on informe en fait les
automobilistes parfois de radio ou par
voie de sms qui sont bloqués dans le
secteur compte youtube qui vont être
traitées et qu'ils ont telle possibilité
de laisser leur véhicule parce qu'il ya
un centre d'accueil et peut-être pas
très bon quels retours d'expérience pour
vous je tournant pour éviter ces
nouvelle débandade
non je suis ta chute suite aux
intempéries là on va sachant qu'en plus
derrière il ya aussi sur certaines zones
il y aura aussi des questions de crues
qui seront peut-être une deuxième couche
en séparant encore qui sont encore en
zone de crue et en plus mais bon je
pense qu'on fera un débrief auprès de
auprès des parents de façon à voir si
ils ont décidé quand même d'envoyer
leurs enfants à l'école malgré les
recommandations qu'ils ont pu avoir de
la part de leur établissement et et puis
de voir avec avec la préfecture et puis
avec ta des élèves n quels sont les les
la meilleure façon enfin la première des
choses c'est de faire en sorte que les
enfants se retrouvent pas en danger
c'est à dire que par exemple un bus qui
laisse des enfants parce qu'il est
bloqué qui les oblige à descendre là ça
ça il fait il faisait moins - 1 - 2
enfin ça va entre guillemets il n'y
avait pas un vent monstrueux mais si
vous vous retrouvez avec des conditions
qui font que ces enfants
ne trouve pas un abri et c'est ça ça
peut poser problème donc moi aussi je
suis plutôt de nature optimiste on voit
que les uns et les autres essaient de
trouver des solutions
et si certains ont vécu quelque chose
qui est qu'il n'est pas qu'ils estiment
ne pas être normal faut pas qu'ils
hésitent à venir en discuter et à partir
de ce moment là on verra ce qu'on peut
faire pour améliorer la chose en main
tenant compte que aussi chaque citoyen
du fait de ne pas prendre sa voiture ou
de 1 peut aider aussi à résoudre ce
problème général d'écouté merci beaucoup
ce sera le mot de la fin
merci beaucoup à vous d'avoir participé
à cette émission quant à vous je vous
invite à voir voir revoir cette émission
sur notre site internet passé une
excellente soirée et la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]